is super like relax we're shooting from
the hip super relaxed should I sleep
[Laughter]
this is Cody
Melchior and this is cameras just saw
and Cody also Jess and we're wearing
green because we're filming this on st.
Patrick's Day yes sure and begorrah
that's an Irish thing oh thanks I know
that one from luck of the Irish
the we just watched Beauty and the Beast
I grew up this was my favorite Disney
film growing up okay I'm at the Hercules
kid and also of mine had a crush on
Hercules in retrospect hmm I definitely
wanted to be one of the hot ladies who
sang in Hercules so the muses come from
the back they have names
what could you also have the missus part
I was like I'm just obsessed with the
inanimate water-bearing objects um in
high school with Rachel t2 so of you
know she was Bell I was not in that this
is a reaction video we're not reviewing
it and it by any means there may be
spoilers but everyone knows the story of
Beauty and the Beast it's a tale as old
as time that was so good there will be a
spoiler specific to the story that is
specific to this movie that most people
watching this will understand we're
talking about and that would be the the
gay elephant in the room that isn't
enjoyed the movie for the most part in a
way that's like I didn't need this but
it's fine and then the end kind of
redeemed it for me I would I pretty much
cosign that I think it's true for most
Disney movies and really a lot of movies
today in general is the supporting cast
usually ends up saving the day oh yeah
the ending was great you know I think
when beast transforms he could get it
but I was fine watching it it was
enjoyable
there's one weird moment that's new to
this movie it's a song but we'll talk
about okay and I will say that the
fundamental problem which we've
discussed is when you make it live
action
it makes beasts to rule and that whole
she don't above a lion thing becomes
real unnerving
gets under your skin right I mean look I
know what you're thinking you're like no
but that's true for the cartoon as well
but in the cartoon
he's a two-dimensional cel shaded
creature and also in the live-action one
at one point he's just like hairy buffed
shirtless dude in the bed and like when
he turns away it's like okay from behind
you know I'm just saying you know okay I
love Emma Watson yes I think she's super
I mean maybe the most beautiful woman
I've ever laid eyes on
I think she has killer eyebrows it's
just like could naming a couple things I
love she is not a vocalist and everyone
kind of knows this going in it doesn't
usually bother me in movies I saw a lava
lands they're not vocalist didn't bother
me at all this it just didn't hit the
mark it was passable I'll say she was
better as much as I loved Emma Stone she
was a better singer than Emma Stone was
in yeah all the Emma's are great they
truly are the Zac Efron's of women added
songs yeah they didn't put in home which
I'm like why are you adding songs and
not putting in home which is a beautiful
song are you doing that right they took
out a bunch of my favorite Disney
classics from this one they took out go
the distance they took out make a man
out of you kiss the girl they took out
kiss the girl and I was like there are
my favorites there's what I referred to
as a Phantom of the Opera moment a spot
where he just he sings a torch song of
forlorn which also I believe that was
the same song that also and no no that
was a different song that involved three
actors that they hired for no reason to
play child beast his mother and his
father and we saw them for literally
three seconds and never again you
literally just paid three three extras
to be to be friends Center you and you
got costuming for them and put makeup on
them and they just stood there I'm
hoping that it was supposed to be as
hell yeah that kid sorry are not wig
shaming a child we are week shaving the
costuming Department who are all adults
it may no better way I would describe
the child is Brad Pitt's character in
interview of the
vampire as a child yeah like chippy Brad
Pitt vampire I mean that movie all the
way through but I know I have the visual
my my camera hasn't seen part of I have
a lot of those so the beast has this
like soliloquy song moment where he
stands on a parapet and just sings
forlornly about the concepts of love and
loss and just and and and really he
could have just like laid down on a
piano honestly and it's very epic it's
supposed to be very epic it shot
epically and all the notes aren't
impressive that he's singing yeah that
one actually bothered me way more than
Emma singing because it was supposed to
be such a powerfully swelling song like
I don't think I'm ever had a song where
it was like a huge you know like the
Tigers come at night moment which is
what home I suppose to be and then they
cut that maybe because she couldn't see
me right here we got a conspiracy yeah
I'm pretty sure camera and I just
laughed the entire time silently to
ourselves it starts and you're like oh
god what's happening yeah yeah like the
moment he just like I think he like
turns and goes like what if I because
Leo that sounded almost like another
bummed me out was that not mmm I can
count on like one hand how many jokes
like really works for me the jokes fell
so flat yes I says a lot about the jokes
that Emma would Emma Watson get smacked
in the face with a giant snowball I know
it was funny but Cody was
[Music]
I'm surprised he didn't break her nose
and that would have been a great twist
though that would have been the true
lesson
I liked the edgy darkness that they
brought into it and I wish that they
would have combated that with some
actual comedy I'd agree yeah that's like
that's that should be the thing that
Disney excels at um and also it says a
lot that we just said the sentence or
Tamra just said the Siddhant I liked the
edgy darkness they brought to beauty in
the beach
so when they introduced him though I was
like holy this is like he's a
little intimidating I'm free oh yeah
yeah yeah I will say that much like it
was a lot like um it was a lot like that
scene in rogue one with Darth Vader
where you suddenly realize oh this is
why everyone's afraid of Darth Vader
very similar to this where it's like Oh
beast is actually a terrifying creature
because in the cartoon he's so cute
it gets then really awkward when the
love part starts happening because it's
such an a sudden shift yeah but she's
like she falls in love with him pretty
quick hey you know Stockholm Syndrome
happens fast what's going on genitals
wives you know I'm saying just like so
like we all know that most mammals not
most a fair number of mammals have a
baculum which is the bone that sticks
the penis out yes so right so yes dogs
polar bears raccoons um so the thing is
he's a buff alliant right so like under
lids which are like hooved animals don't
but he's not hooved and some cats have
them so it's like you got a penis bone
is what I'm wondering
and like that too much let's not get
weird but you know time passes poorly in
the live-action version versus the
animated one you're never really sure
how much times going on
things happen more concurrently with
Kevin Kline as the father as Bell's
father Maurice because we keep checking
in with him so much it seems like times
not passing as quickly seems like this
all took place in a week right cuz
that's the thing it's like yeah be in
the cartoon it felt like you were
getting glimpses of all of these like
moments that were happening over all
this period of time until you get to the
end and the whole the wonderful scene
like the whole the villagers come and
they try to kill the Beast
and I love that I love I love it when
they come to kill the Beast
love that killing scenes like we said
it's a side character assume like really
bring things like up a knife yeah that's
a really tragic moment where at the end
were they all like turned in an anime
and it's yeah I was done is she
and I was just not expecting it because
I hadn't felt true great emotional then
everyone likes seeing each other first
time in their human forms is really
beautiful that was done well a little
weird ADR stuff going on there in terms
of audio the dialogue replacement that
they do there was a lot of like people
talking off camera at the end which felt
a little disjointed for me but I also I
you know I do film stuff so I'd probably
notice I'm probably somebody who would
notice that more then McGregor was
Lumiere that was interesting I love him
yeah he's great he was one of my first
crushes of all time in Star Wars I loved
him he's know Zac Efron give a child a
buff we're like my two celebrity oh man
your crushes your crush is turning poor
Thompson Watson Watson Emma Stone Emma
Emma Bunton felt yeah Emma Thompson
right yeah I think so and I adore her
with all of my heart yes so that was I
was I was also very happy that Nanny
McPhee was playing a team Deborah's
never to see nanny mcphee Don had a
killer voice yeah sing yeah I wish he
had been a little more front and center
in the guest on song though yeah it felt
it felt like it felt more like Lefou
song then guest on song as far as I
remember the guest on song going and the
comedy in that the nothing in that
landed for me now anyways and there was
also a very weird moment where Lefou
says he bites no one bites like Gaston
and lifts up his shirt he has a bite
mark on his stomach and that was very
confusing considering all of the coding
that they had been giving in terms of
the homosexuality aspect I was like wait
Sarah is that are you painting that like
they had hooked up right so Lefou starts
off as you would imagine I think it's
all been expected where he's just you
know he's the sidekick Patsy he's super
obsessed with Gaston loves him and and
says a lot of you know
statements to that effect
very clear also though I want to say
it's not crazy in the spectrum of
stereotypical like I said they didn't go
yeah later during the kill the Beast
moment on the invasion one of gas Don's
a three of gas Don's dudes go up to
fight Cogswell and then her consort and
the dresser comes in dresses them up in
like fancy women's outfits from that era
two of them get upset run away but one
of them is happy about it like there's
like a weird moment where he like smiles
and thinks he looks pretty the weirdest
moment like that's really weird moment
like what was that and so it's like a
kind of problematic thing of like you
know the whole thing of like boys
wearing dresses it's also a confusion of
sexuality and gender to some extent at
the very end of the movie there's the
big ballroom dancing and wedding and
they're all dancing and the fuzz dancing
with a woman it's the world we're like
oh that's kind of like woman
and then there's this one moment where
they spin the guy from earlier from the
pretty boy moment into laughs oh and
they have like a connection moment that
did kind of retro actively redeem a fair
amount of what was going on
is it is it the greatest first gay
character well first explicitly gay
character in a Disney movie to some
extent not the greatest but a good way
right and I mean at this point in my
life I'm willing to take what I can and
on that note thank you so much for being
on with me thank you for having me I
adore you um it was a pleasure remember
go out there that Buffalo
[Laughter]